travel more facts Britain's housing
mortgage markets in meltdown and estate
agent jaspal signi fears for his
business the government's plan for
sweeping tax cuts to huge amounts of
borrowing spooked investors forcing
dozens of lenders to pull hundreds of
mortgage deals buyers are understandably
quite anxious about what's going to
happen next um I think the key thing
we've got to remember is buyers are also
sellers we're seeing the lower level of
buyers coming to the markets we're at a
40 reduction in buyers actually
registering who've got mortgages
approved in principle and this is even I
think this trend is going to continue
just with with obviously suspension on
certain mortgage products while buyers
and sellers re-evaluate their options
the international monetary fund the
lender of Last Resort
urged the British government to
reconsider cutting taxes at a time of
soaring inflation the IMF fears it will
spark a global slowdown and risks
widening inequality the kind of warning
the IMF gives to emerging economies not
the UK
last Friday the chancellor of the
exchecker announced a bonanza of tax
cuts and debt-funded spending in the
hopes of stimulating economic growth but
the move has spectacularly backfired the
value of the pound plummeting to its
lowest level since 1985. the whole
Market is in turmoil at the moment and
people are waiting for some conciliatory
tones from having that the chancellor or
the bank of England to actually settle
the markets down and at the moment that
hasn't been forthcoming the figures
forced the bank of England on Wednesday
to take evasive action and buy
government bonds on a temporary basis to
help calm the market but within minutes
the pound fell again down 1.6 against
the dollar
as the pound Falls the cost of
government borrowing on the
international bond markets has gone up
from an interest rate of around one and
a half to two and a half percent to five
percent seemingly overnight expressing a
real lack of Confidence from investors
about the government's ability to pay
for its own plans UK debt is now seen by
investors as being similar to Greece or
Italy countries with long histories of
economic mismanagement even before all
this inflation the gradual increase in
the price of goods over a year was
around 10 percent it's highest in 40
years and the highest amongst G7
advanced economies a perfect storm of
factors including the war in Ukraine
have disrupted supplies of goods such as
oil wheat and fertilizer pushing up the
price of food Fuel and other items and
in order to dampen those Rises the bank
of England that acts independently of
the government has raised interest rates
the cost of borrowing to slow down
spending and keep prices under control
but the turbulent pound means only one
thing the bank of England responding
with even higher rates of interest to
help steady prices
the heads of some of the world's leading
Banks were summoned to the treasury to
try to restore confidence in the
government's plans but politically
things that anything but stable there's
disquiet amongst MPS from the governing
conservative party some reportedly
calling for Liz truss's Premiership to
end before it's really begun
London